en fait je vais un peu plus loin que
karim je suis d'accord à 100% que si
calme et je vais aller un peu plus loin
et je peux être très agréable en fait
tout ce que vous dites là ça existe
depuis l'aube de l'humanité
le seul qui soit intéressant ce soir à
mon goût c'est fabrice parce que hilda
porte des soins des gens en détresse
pour les autres on a en face de nous la
prostitution on a en face d'eux mêmes
termes en éthique et le libertinage en
afin de nous le cultisme trois mamelles
de l'histoire de l'humanité
[Applaudissements]
je
sentais que ces thèmes là soient
abordées c'est pour ça que jusqu'à
jusqu'à il ya une minute dans le respect
de la modération et les changes soit
mais je ne dis pas que c'est nouveau je
dis simplement qu'on les a abordées de
manière
rationnelle quand je peux
vous dire tout et son contraire mais au
contraire je sais que
justement
c'est au contraire rien inventé c'est
sympa la discussion mais tout à leur
ouïe parmi vos projets des choses
intéressantes effectivement les juifs
étoiles rose etc et là ils dealent
inverse ni les homosexuels était chiant
donc il faut sa mairie
des crises mémorielle d'aider des
propositions mémorielle et départ tous
les biens des conneries aussi
on n'a pas d'aidé
[Applaudissements]
ecoutez-moi route et je n'ai pas là je
vais pas me jouer de voitures face à sa
mère si elle fait ça et qu'ils avaient
des armes qu'ils viennent chercher des
plaisirs c'est qu'elle offre aussi un
service je suis désolé c'est pas de la
constitution
on sait que cet abri ce que moi ce
n'était fabrice est ce que écouter
mairie c'est pas la même chose mais à la
sortie c'est le même principe c'était du
fessier
fabrice mais ils ne soutiennent pas que
les personnes handicapées ce qui pousse
une personne valide des précédents on
pourrait dire connais aussi se
prostituent
le jeu la raison est là où karim a
raison
parce que plus on en parle plus on ouvre
les shojo témoin a évité des essaims
éviter les excès voici les gens du pays
resteront fermés avec eux je me suis
vidé agression parce que du coup il n'y
a pas deux y a pas de réel sur ma ti
breizh engagé pour la vous nous avait
expliqué que vous êtes pour le respect
de l'autre le consentement est tous à
coûteux feu soyez honnête monsieur est
ce que vous pensez que des femmes dans
des maisons closes des femmes qui se
prostituent dans les bois sont dans le
consentement et le donnait à voir mais
c'est pas le cas de libellules a lancé
je parle à monsieur b à bb ça n'a rien
n'est pas constitue dans des bois ou
qu'on se prostituent convent du sexe
je suis absolument je suis absolument
pas favorable à la prostitution mais
elle est là quand même on est là nous on
est là pour nous écouter les cas
particuliers pas faire des généralités
mais j'écoute ce que des libellules
ont même mis directement une étiquette
j'ai même pas eu le temps d'exprimer et
de fermat prévention ont même une
étiquette de prostituées très bien de
toute façon dans tous les cas je suis
une femme qui parle de la secte j'en
rate ici aussi le sait les goûts même
que vous aviez monter cette mais vous
vous le dit d'une manière très péjoratif
mais vous me regardez d'une manière
comme si je suis seule et absolument
pouvoir maintenant mais je me dis juste
que ce que je ressens c'est bon pour ma
femme ah ben non mais oui on regarde
aujourd'hui le manière on m'a invité ici
justement présent dans le jeu parce qu
exactement ce que je fais sur les
réseaux c'est à dire se libérer la
parole et pouvoir qu'on arrête
d'assimiler des choses qui sont vraies
vous n'êtes pas concerné par la pétition
vous n'en savez rien et dijon c'est
madame dominique monnier des femmes
ça fait cinq fois que je dis qu'il faut
conclure flore mais s'il faut le
pratiquer pour l'or qui aura le mot de
la fin en tant que fils rouges chaque
chose que même tout le discours part de
beaucoup de malentendus peut-être une
incompréhension de ce que fait
libellules dans ce jeu c'est pas
vraiment par les libellules voilà de
trouver les peut-être les bons mots pour
toucher ou de faire comprendre
l'activité qu avant tout une activité
d'imaginaire et de fantasmes ce que vont
libellules c'est un fantasme et elle le
travail et c'est des compétences c'est
pas vendre un corps de vendre une
attitude et créant je monte je tourne
j'apprends et les motrices et macho est
un art vu dans le sexe je pense que mis
à part ces mariages et balla bèye
convaincre libellules d'arrêter je suis
là pour dire aux jeunes filles de ne pas
le faire mais je le fais déjà ne
t'inquiète pas je le fais déjà très bien
se marrer c'est juste qu'on mérite la
même des choses mais j'aurais compris là
dessus parce que c'est important on le
fait aussi que la pression ça qu il
permet dire quoi vous vous d'expliquer
que cette jeune femme et le jeune homme
que c'est pas quelque chose d'anodin
c'est pas quelque chose de facile ses
pages aux gagnants il y aurait pas de
personne c'est un vrai métier c'est des
vrais engagements c'est quelque chose
qui peut effectivement être dangereux
d'accord donc et je ne vous le fait
régulièrement je l'espère désabonner
savent très bien il faut le redire s'il
y aura peut-être un temps des deux mois
soit juste faire du mal grâce à lui et
lui a tordu de moins qu'il ya qui s'est
passé à l'action moi je m'occupe des
gens qui ont des fantasmes à un
particulier qui sort de l'ordinaire où
il veut mais qu'ils le fassent avec moi
qui l'ait fabien michel verjux